This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the fall of 1999, a new film debuted in just 25 theaters across the United States. Its name was Being John Malkovich. The premise was outlandish. A down on his luck puppeteer named Craig finds a small hidden door at the office where he works. When he crawls inside, he goes through a strange portal and ends up inside the mind of the actor, John Malcol. For 15 minutes or so, he gets to inhabit the actor's body before being spit out on the side of the New Jersey turnpike. Things only get more wacky from there. Craig and a co-worker start charging people to go through the portal, and soon, plenty of people have had the experience of being John Malkovich.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1999年秋，一部新电影在美国仅有的25家影院上映。它的名字叫《成为约翰·马尔科维奇》。其前提非常离奇。一位走投无路的木偶师克雷格在他工作的办公室里发现了一扇隐藏的小门。当他爬进去时，他穿过了一个奇怪的入口，最终进入了演员约翰·马尔科维奇的大脑。大约15分钟后，他得以占据这位演员的身体，然后被吐在新泽西收费公路的路边。从那以后，事情变得更加古怪。克雷格和一位同事开始向人们收费，让他们穿过这个入口，很快，许多人都体验了成为约翰·马尔科维奇的感觉。
When John Malkovich, the real John Malkovich, inevitably learns about this, he is determined to go to go through the portal himself. When he does so, he enters a world where everyone has his face and can only say one word. The movie is thought-provoking and has long been one of my favorites. That might be because it is a metaphor for a central idea that we explore on this show. We like to think that we are in charge of our own minds. We decide what we are going to think and what we are going to do. We decide what to cook for dinner, where to go on vacation, and whom to marry.
当约翰·马尔科维奇，真正的约翰·马尔科维奇，不可避免地得知此事时，他决心亲自穿过这个入口。当他这样做时，他进入了一个每个人都长着他的脸且只能说一个词的世界。这部电影发人深省，长期以来一直是我最喜欢的电影之一。这可能是因为它隐喻了我们在本节目中探讨的一个核心思想。我们喜欢认为自己掌控着自己的思想。我们决定自己要思考什么，要做什么。我们决定晚餐吃什么，去哪里度假，以及和谁结婚。
But it turns out that there are a vast number of unconscious mental processes that direct much of how we think and act. Often, we are unaware of these hidden puppeteers. They make us say and do things that we haven't consciously chosen ourselves. Sadly, there's no way to spit these puppeteers out on the side of the New Jersey turnpike. It's my head, Schwartz. It's my head! This week on Hidden Brain, why our minds often conspire against our best interests and how we can regain some control over the puppet masters pulling at our strings. Where there's a will, there's a way.
但事实证明，有大量的无意识心理过程在引导着我们的思维和行为方式。通常，我们并没有意识到这些隐藏的木偶师。他们让我们说出和做出我们并未自觉选择的事情。可悲的是，没有办法把这些木偶师吐在新泽西收费公路的路边。那是我的头，施瓦茨。那是我的头！本周在《Hidden Brain》中，我们将探讨为什么我们的思想经常违背我们的最大利益，以及我们如何才能重新获得对操纵我们丝线的木偶大师的一些控制权。有志者，事竟成。
Most of us have been raised to believe that if we want to get something done, we need only to set our minds to it. And yet something odd and discouraging often happens when we set out to lose weight or exercise more or save money. Somehow we end up polishing off that pint of ice cream in the freezer or skipping our session at the gym or once again spending more than our budget allows. It's not what we set up.
我们大多数人从小就被教导，如果我们想完成某件事，只需要下定决心去做就行了。然而，当我们着手减肥、多运动或存钱时，往往会发生一些奇怪且令人沮丧的事情。不知何故，我们最终还是吃光了冰箱里那品脱冰淇淋，或者错过了健身课程，或者再次花费超过了预算。这不是我们设定的。
out to do, but it seems as if we are not the ones in charge. Emily Falk is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Pennsylvania. She studies how we make choices and how we can initiate change in our lives. Emily Fock, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Emily, I understand that you recently made a promise to yourself about what you would eat at a graduation ceremony that featured many desserts at the buffet. What was the promise you made to yourself?
我们原本打算做的事情，但看起来好像我们并不是掌控者。艾米丽·福克是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她研究我们如何做出选择以及我们如何能够在生活中引发改变。艾米丽·福克，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢你的邀请。艾米丽，我听说你最近对自己做了一个承诺，关于你在一个自助餐上有许多甜点的毕业典礼上会吃什么。你对自己做了什么承诺？
Well, I was in the very exciting situation that there were many desserts that looked delicious. And I was very curious, so I wanted to try all of them. But I knew, of course, that if I ate many different desserts, I would not feel amazing afterwards. So I decided that I was going to get one of each of them, try each one, and then eat the full thing from the one I liked the best. I went and I sat down, and I did try each of them, and it turned out that they were delicious. I was also in a ceremony that was about an hour long, and they were just there in front of me. And so in the moment, it went well in the sense that I had many desserts in front of me and a lot of time. So I ate them, and that was really fun for a little while until it wasn't.
嗯，我当时处于一个非常令人兴奋的情况，有很多看起来很美味的甜点。我很好奇，所以我想尝试所有的甜点。但我当然知道，如果我吃了很多不同的甜点，之后我不会感觉很好。所以我决定，我要每样拿一个，每样都尝尝，然后把我最喜欢的那一个吃完。我走过去坐下，确实每样都尝了，结果它们都很美味。我参加的仪式大约持续了一个小时，它们就摆在我面前。所以在那一刻，事情进展得很顺利，因为我面前有很多甜点，而且时间充裕。所以我吃了它们，有一会儿确实很有趣，直到后来不再有趣。
when emily got home she swore to her partner brett that she was only going to eat healthy foods the rest of the day oh man well i went and i lay down on the couch and i said i am so sugared up i am not going to eat any more sugar today and what happened a little embarrassed to tell you what happened what happened was um that evening We went out to dinner with my grandma Bev, and there's a diner in her building called Little Peets. And we went there and had what my kids considered to be probably the ideal meal, including things like, you know, a griddled, grilled cheese and waffles and things that you get at a diner. And at dessert time, the kids said they wanted a milkshake. And my kid Emmett asked the waiter, how big is the milkshake? and the waiter said it's pretty big
当艾米丽回到家时，她向她的伴侣布雷特发誓，她当天剩下的时间只吃健康的食物。天哪，好吧，我躺在沙发上说，我摄入了太多糖分，今天我不会再吃任何糖了。然后发生了什么？有点不好意思告诉你发生了什么。发生的事情是，那天晚上我们和我的祖母贝芙出去吃晚饭，她住的楼里有一家叫“小皮特”的餐馆。我们去了那里，吃了我孩子们认为可能是理想的一餐，包括像烤奶酪三明治和华夫饼之类的东西，这些都是你在餐馆里能吃到的。到了甜点时间，孩子们说他们想要奶昔。我的孩子埃米特问服务员，奶昔有多大？服务员说很大。
and so I said why don't you guys split the milkshake? So they agreed to that deal and the waiter brought out two fairly sizable glasses full of milkshake which I assumed was half in each glass but no he also had one of those large metal containers like you get at a soda fountain
所以我说，你们为什么不分着喝那杯奶昔呢？他们同意了这个交易，服务员拿出了两杯相当大的奶昔，我以为每杯是一半，但没有，他还拿出了一个像你在苏打喷泉店里看到的那种大金属容器。
and he handed it to me and that contained just as much milkshake so he gave me this enormous milkshake And basically, what was I going to do, right? Like, I didn't want to sugar my kids up anymore. Milkshakes are delicious. So despite the fact that directly before coming to this dinner, I had just said to Brett and my kids,
他把它递给了我，里面装的奶昔和杯子里的一样多，所以他给了我这杯巨大的奶昔。基本上，我能怎么办呢，对吧？我不想再让我的孩子们摄入糖分了。奶昔很美味。所以尽管在来吃这顿饭之前，我刚刚对布雷特和我的孩子们说，
I am not going to eat any more sugar today. I am just going to detox and eat all the green vegetables and feel amazing later. I proceeded to polish off the entire rest of that milkshake. I'm reminded Emily of that perceptive scene from the sitcom Friends. Chandler and Rachel find themselves eating a cheesecake that was supposed to be delivered to a neighbor. When a second cheesecake arrives, they vow not to eat it and place the dessert outside the door of the rightful owner.
我今天不会再吃任何糖了。我只是要排毒，吃所有的绿色蔬菜，以后感觉棒极了。我接着吃光了剩下的整杯奶昔。艾米丽，我被情景喜剧《老友记》中那个敏锐的场景提醒了。钱德勒和瑞秋发现自己在吃一份本应送给邻居的芝士蛋糕。当第二个芝士蛋糕送来时，他们发誓不吃它，并把甜点放在了合法所有者的门外。
But soon enough, they find the cheesecake has not yet been picked up. Do you see what I see? It's still there. Mrs. Braverman must be out. She could be out of town. Maybe she'll be gone for months. By then, the cheesecake may have gone bad. We don't want her to come back to bad cheesecake.
但很快，他们发现芝士蛋糕还没被拿走。你看到我看到的了吗？它还在那儿。布雷弗曼太太一定出去了。她可能出城了。也许她会离开几个月。到那时，芝士蛋糕可能已经坏了。我们不想让她回来时面对坏掉的芝士蛋糕。
No, that could kill her. Well, we don't want that. No, so we're protecting her. Well, we should take it? Yeah, but we should move quick. Why? Because I think I just heard her moving around in there. Go, go, go.
不，那可能会害死她。好吧，我们不想那样。不，所以我们在保护她。好吧，我们应该拿走它吗？是的，但我们应该快点。为什么？因为我想我刚才听到她在里面走动。快，快，快。
So I understand that part of your motivation in having that milkshake, Emily, was you wanted to shield your children from the dangers of too much sugar. That sounds a lot like what Chandler and Rachel were doing in the scene. Yeah, I mean, that's certainly something that I said verbally at the time. table. I mean, Brett did remind me of the resolution that I'd made earlier to be kind to my body and not totally poisoned myself with large amounts of sugar. And I had a milkshake in my hand, and I said, well, I have a milkshake and it looks delicious. So that was a pretty good argument. I'm wondering, Emily, what you make of this, because I feel many. people go through what you go through, which is that we want to do something, we aspire to do
所以我明白你喝那杯奶昔的部分动机是，艾米丽，你想保护你的孩子免受过多糖分的危害。这听起来很像钱德勒和瑞秋在那个场景中所做的事情。是的，我的意思是，那确实是我当时口头上说的话。桌子上。我的意思是，布雷特确实提醒了我之前做出的要善待我的身体、不要用大量糖分彻底毒害自己的决定。我手里拿着奶昔，我说，好吧，我有一杯奶昔，它看起来很美味。所以那是一个相当好的论点。艾米丽，我想知道你对此有何看法，因为我觉得很多人都经历过你所经历的事情，那就是我们想做某事，我们渴望做
something, we plan to do something, and then somehow we don't. Exactly. And this happens in all different parts of our lives. It happens with work projects that maybe we wish we had gotten to invest in a little bit more or school projects if we're still in school. It happens with decisions where there's some kind of payoff that's far off in the future. Maybe we want to do something because we know that it'll make us healthier, happier later. It happens with the people that we care about and making time to spend time with them when they're available and when we still can.
某事，我们计划做某事，然后不知何故我们没有做。没错。这种情况发生在我们生活的各个方面。它发生在工作项目中，也许我们希望我们能多投入一点，或者如果我们还在上学的话，发生在学校项目中。它发生在那些回报在遥远未来的决策中。也许我们想做某事，因为我们知道它会让我们以后更健康、更快乐。它发生在我们在乎的人身上，以及在他们有空且我们还能抽出时间时与他们共度时光。
So that's just a small set of examples. There are so many times where we make these kinds of choices and then later we wonder why we made them. Have you heard this from your students, from your partner, from your children? Yeah, I've heard this, everybody that I know experiences this. One example that comes to mind is my grandma, Bev, every time I see her regrets that she hasn't been reading books. And I ask her, you know, why haven't you been reading books?
所以这只是一小部分例子。我们有很多次做出这种选择，然后后来想知道为什么我们做出这些选择。你从你的学生、你的伴侣、你的孩子那里听到过这些吗？是的，我听过，我认识的每个人都经历过这种情况。我想到的一个例子是我的祖母贝芙，每次我见到她，她都后悔自己没有读书。我问她，你知道，你为什么不读书？
She loves reading books. And she says, well, there's just so many things that I need to do. And I ask her about what those things are. And it's usually things that have to do with basic, you know, cleaning up her apartment or doing errands, things that take some time. And I say, well, why don't you just carve out some time and read some books? And she's like, I'll do it tomorrow. or you know my kids are extremely interested in a wide range of things that they would like to be doing
她喜欢读书。她说，嗯，有太多事情我需要做。我问她那些事情是什么。通常是关于基本的，你知道，打扫她的公寓或跑腿，那些需要一些时间的事情。我说，好吧，你为什么不抽出一些时间读点书呢？她说，我明天会做的。或者你知道我的孩子们对他们想做的各种各样的事情非常感兴趣，
and then sometimes on the weekend when they're allowed to have screen time they end up playing a ton of Minecraft and then later they feel frustrated that they didn't do all those other things that they had in their plan for the weekend those are two small examples that come to mind I mean this also happens all the time with my team at work, like when people are doing research and we meet and we discuss all of the ambitions that we have for the things that we're going to do and then we meet with each other a week later and only a very small number of the things that were actually on the list maybe have been accomplished. And it's not that anybody has been slacking off or anybody had bad intentions, but just that everything always takes longer than you think and then other things
然后有时在周末，当他们被允许使用屏幕时间时，他们最终玩了大量的《我的世界》，然后后来他们感到沮丧，因为他们没有做周末计划中的所有其他事情。这些是我能想到的两个小例子。我的意思是，这在我的工作团队中也经常发生，比如当人们在做研究时，我们开会讨论我们对将要做的事情的所有雄心壮志，然后我们一周后见面，实际上清单上只有极少数事情可能已经完成了。并不是有人在偷懒或有人有坏意图，只是每件事总是比你想象的要花更长的时间，然后其他事情
come up. And sometimes there's 20 things that didn't make it onto that original to-do list but that we're really important in the moment. So this phenomenon of failing to follow through is so common that it's become a trope in many films and TV shows. I want to play you a clip from the television series Parks and Recreation. The character Ron Swanson has had a really bad relationship with this woman but keeps getting back with her. After one of their traumatic breakups,
就会出现。有时有20件事没有进入最初的待办事项清单，但在那一刻确实很重要。所以这种未能坚持到底的现象非常普遍，以至于它成为了许多电影和电视节目中的一个桥段。我想给你播放一段电视剧《公园与游憩》的片段。角色罗恩·斯旺森和这个女人关系非常糟糕，但一直和她复合。在他们其中一次痛苦的分手后，
he records a message to his future self. Hello, Ron. It's Ron. If you're watching this, it means that once again you have danced with the devil. Right now, you're probably thinking, Tammy's changed, we'll be happy together. But you're only thinking that because she's a monstrous parasite who entered through your privates and lodged herself in your brain. So, you have two choices. One, get rid of Tammy. Or two, lobotomy and castration. Choose wisely. So, Emily, what do you hear when you hear that warning that Ron is giving to himself? Yeah, I mean, what I hear is somebody who has tried to do something in the past, right?
他给未来的自己录了一段信息。你好，罗恩。我是罗恩。如果你在看这个，这意味着你又一次与魔鬼共舞了。现在，你可能在想，塔米变了，我们会幸福地在一起。但你之所以这么想，是因为她是一个寄生虫，通过你的私处进入并驻扎在你的大脑里。所以，你有两个选择。第一，摆脱塔米。或者第二，切除前额叶和阉割。明智地选择。所以，艾米丽，当你听到罗恩给自己的那个警告时，你听到了什么？是的，我的意思是，我听到的是一个过去尝试做某事的人，对吧？
He set a goal, and then other things that he hadn't accounted for come up. And so he gets back together with Tammy. And clearly, he's done this multiple times because he's made a video and tried to protect himself against it in the future, right? So we do this all the time. we try to talk to ourselves or make resolutions or write down ideas about how our future selves should behave. I'm wondering in some ways if this is like the story of, you know, Ulysses tying himself to the mast of his own ship. I mean, this is a problem that really goes back to mythology, to ancient times. I mean, the challenge that we often have in overcoming what seems to be, you know, almost a hijacker who lives inside our own heads.
他设定了一个目标，然后其他他没有考虑到的事情出现了。所以他和塔米复合了。显然，他已经多次这样做，因为他制作了一个视频并试图在未来保护自己，对吧？所以我们一直这样做。我们试图对自己说话，或者做出决议，或者写下关于我们未来的自己应该如何表现的想法。我想知道在某些方面这是否就像尤利西斯把自己绑在自己船的桅杆上的故事。我的意思是，这是一个真正可以追溯到神话、古代的问题。我的意思是，我们在克服似乎生活在我们自己头脑中的劫持者时经常面临的挑战。
Yeah, I mean, it's an idea that goes back for centuries. millennia and it's also an idea that's represented in all kinds of modern media and like the clips you played earlier it's funny because we can relate to it right it's funny because it's so common that none of us is thinking why are chandler and rachel interested in eating more of the cheesecake or you know well ron should just be able to stop himself because so many of us have been in that kind of situation So often, we sincerely want to make changes in our behavior, changes that we know would leave us better off.
是的，我的意思是，这是一个可以追溯到几个世纪、几千年的想法，它也是一种在各种现代媒体中表现出来的想法，就像你之前播放的片段一样，这很有趣，因为我们可以感同身受，对吧？这很有趣，因为它太普遍了，我们没有人会想为什么钱德勒和瑞秋有兴趣吃更多的芝士蛋糕，或者你知道，罗恩应该能够阻止自己，因为我们很多人都处于那种情况。通常，我们真诚地想要改变我们的行为，我们知道这些改变会让我们变得更好。
And almost as often, we end up not making those changes to our own frustration and bafflement. When we come back, the mysterious but powerful presence inside our heads that works against our conscious goals to improve our. lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. She studies why our resolutions often fail and what we can do about it. Emily, most of us imagine that if there's a choice we want to make or a change we want to initiate, we can simply decide to do it and then we will carry through. Your study of the brain suggests that there's more to this process,
而几乎同样频繁地，我们最终没有做出这些改变，这让我们感到沮丧和困惑。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们头脑中那个神秘但强大的存在，它违背了我们改善生活的自觉目标。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。她研究为什么我们的决议经常失败以及我们能对此做些什么。艾米丽，我们大多数人想象，如果我们想做出一个选择或引发一个改变，我们可以简单地决定去做，然后我们就会坚持到底。你对大脑的研究表明，这个过程还有更多内容，
in particular a network known as the value system gets involved whenever we face a decision. What is this value system? The value system is a constellation of brain regions that handle our choices, the choices that we're making consciously between, you know, drinking a milkshake or not drinking a milkshake between, you know, whether we're going to go out on a date with somebody or stay home and deal with our emails. And the value system calculates these choices in what neuroscientists call a value calculation. So in some ways it's doing a sort of cost-benefit analysis? Yeah, basically for each of our choices, it's identifying what are the different things that we're choosing between. It's assigning a subjective value to each of those different choices that depends on our current context, our past experiences, our future goals. And then based on that subjective value, that subjective reward that it's anticipating from each of the choices,
特别是每当我们面临决定时，一个被称为价值系统的网络就会参与进来。这个价值系统是什么？价值系统是一组处理我们选择的大脑区域，我们有意识地做出的选择，你知道，在喝奶昔或不喝奶昔之间，你知道，在我们要和某人约会还是待在家里处理电子邮件之间。价值系统以神经科学家所说的价值计算来计算这些选择。所以从某种程度上说，它是在进行一种成本效益分析？是的，基本上对于我们的每一个选择，它都在识别我们正在选择的不同事物。它根据我们当前的背景、过去的经历、未来的目标，为每一个不同的选择分配一个主观价值。然后基于那个主观价值，它从每个选择中预期的那个主观奖励，
it chooses the one that it thinks is going to be the best for me right here, right now, and then it is connected to other brain systems that take action that's relevant to that choice. So you raise something really important here just now, which is that the value system is really focused on the here and now. So when Emily says, I don't want to eat too much dessert or too much. sugar because that's not going to be good for me in the long run. But then Emily is confronting three delicious desserts that are sitting in front of her on the table. The value system has to make a judgment and it has to prioritize either the short term or the long term. Exactly. So when I'm
它选择它认为此时此地对我最好的那个，然后它连接到其他大脑系统，采取与该选择相关的行动。所以你刚才提到了一个非常重要的事情，那就是价值系统确实专注于此时此地。所以当艾米丽说，我不想吃太多的甜点或太多的糖，因为从长远来看那对我不好。但随后艾米丽面对着摆在她面前桌子上的三份美味甜点。价值系统必须做出判断，它必须优先考虑短期或长期。没错。所以当我
trying to decide whether I'm going to eat the delicious dessert that's sitting in front of me, the short-term reward of how delicious it's going to taste is more salient. That weighs more heavily in that value calculation than the long-term consequence if I do that. over and over again over the course of years or even how I'm going to feel tomorrow or later this evening. And you can see how this works in all kinds of different ways. If I'm making a choice between buying some expensive gizmo or saving for my retirement, the expensive gizmo gives me a joy and a pleasure in the here and now. And saving for retirement is a very far off benefit. Right. Not only is it far off, but it's less vivid, right? I can totally imagine how much fun
试图决定我是否要吃摆在我面前的美味甜点时，它尝起来有多美味的短期奖励更显著。在那个价值计算中，这比如果我一遍又一遍地这样做多年后的长期后果，甚至比我明天或今天晚些时候的感觉更重要。你可以看到这是如何以各种不同的方式运作的。如果我在购买昂贵的小玩意或为退休存钱之间做出选择，昂贵的小玩意在此时此地给了我快乐和愉悦。而为退休存钱是一个非常遥远的好处。没错。它不仅遥远，而且不那么生动，对吧？我可以完全想象玩那个摆在我面前的玩具会有多有趣，
it's going to be to play with that toy right here that's in front of me. whereas who knows what kind of toys are going to be available during my retirement. So very often the tradeoffs we consider involve what you might call apples and oranges. They're very different choices that we often have to evaluate. And, you know, in the real world, we might establish committees to compare these very different choices. But somehow our brains reduce the complexity of these choices and turn messy real-world decisions into simple choices. You say it's useful to think of this value calculation as a hidden. game of would you rather. What do you mean by that, Emily? Well, you're probably familiar with
而谁知道我退休时会有什么样的玩具呢？所以我们考虑的权衡通常涉及你可能称之为苹果和橘子的东西。它们是非常不同的选择，我们经常必须评估。而且，你知道，在现实世界中，我们可能会建立委员会来比较这些非常不同的选择。但不知何故，我们的大脑简化了这些选择的复杂性，并将混乱的现实世界决策变成了简单的选择。你说把这个价值计算看作一个隐藏的“你宁愿”游戏很有用。艾米丽，你是什么意思？嗯，你可能熟悉
the party game, would you rather, where I might ask you different kinds of things that are usually not as simple as the option that you brought up. Like, would you rather eat an apple or an orange? Or would you rather eat a blueberry tart or a lemon cheesecake? Though, of course, the value system can handle those kinds of would you rather choices. But I also think it's pretty incredible that it can handle the more abstract kind of choices that we usually give it at a party that are not inherently comparable. Like, would you rather have a cat's tongue or would you rather have roller skates for hands? Right. Like, those are totally different things. And it's not like you can directly compare what the advantages and disadvantages would be, but you might have some
派对游戏“你宁愿”，在那里我可能会问你通常不像你提出的选项那么简单的不同类型的事情。比如，你宁愿吃苹果还是橘子？或者你宁愿吃蓝莓塔还是柠檬芝士蛋糕？当然，价值系统可以处理那些类型的“你宁愿”选择。但我还认为，它能处理我们在派对上通常给它的那种本质上不可比较的更抽象的选择，这真是太不可思议了。比如，你宁愿有猫的舌头还是宁愿手变成旱冰鞋？没错。就像，那些是完全不同的东西。而且并不是说你可以直接比较利弊，但你可能对你会选择哪一个有一些
intuition about which one you would choose. You know, when I see some of these questions, would you rather be able to speak every language or have the most beautiful singing voice on earth. Again, very difficult to actually compare and contrast these choices. But again, intuitively, when I think about it, I almost instantly have an answer in my mind about what I would choose. Exactly. Likewise, we can do this with money. Like I could say to you, would you rather have $5 or would you rather snuggle with a puppy? And you could choose whether you'd be willing to pay $5 to snuggle with a puppy or not, and you can probably come up with an answer depending on how you feel about puppies and, you know, how flush you're feeling.
直觉。你知道，当我看到其中一些问题时，你宁愿能说每一种语言还是拥有世界上最美丽的歌声。同样，很难真正比较和对比这些选择。但同样，直觉上，当我思考它时，我几乎立刻就在脑海中有了关于我会选择什么的答案。没错。同样，我们可以用钱来做这件事。比如我可以对你说，你宁愿有5美元还是宁愿和一只小狗依偎？你可以选择你是否愿意付5美元去和小狗依偎，你可能可以根据你对小狗的感觉以及，你知道，你感觉有多宽裕，得出一个答案。
When the value system makes these quick, intuitive calculations, it tends to prioritize the here and now. Of course, most of our resolutions are about prioritizing long-term goals, not short-term gratifications. So what do most of us do when the value system nudges us toward that extra serving of dessert, we try to overcome it using willpower. We tell ourselves to think about the long-term benefits of not yielding to temptation. The problem is, those long-term goals tend to be abstract compared to the tangible pleasures of the here and now. They're essentially far away from us in some way.
当价值系统做出这些快速、直觉的计算时，它倾向于优先考虑此时此地。当然，我们大多数的决议都是关于优先考虑长期目标，而不是短期满足。所以当我们的大脑价值系统引导我们去吃那份额外的甜点时，我们大多数人会怎么做？我们试图用意志力来克服它。我们告诉自己要考虑不屈服于诱惑的长期好处。问题是，与此时此地的有形快乐相比，那些长期目标往往是抽象的。它们本质上在某种程度上离我们很远。
We can't imagine them as vividly. And we can't imagine things as vividly when we think about things that are far off in the future, like, for example, a long-term health benefit of what I choose to eat today or whether I choose to get exercise is offset by, you know, how nice it would feel to stay and watch another show or eat something delicious that is available to me right now. And likewise, those same kinds of abstract tradeoffs come into play when we think about other kinds of shoulds. like I should care about what's happening globally to people who are suffering in other parts of the world. But when that's abstract and, you know, we know statistics about people that are, you know, dying, that's maybe less salient than we hear specific stories about the suffering of a particular individual or even better when we get to know people whose lives are impacted by particular
我们无法生动地想象它们。当我们思考遥远未来的事情时，我们无法生动地想象事物，例如，我今天选择吃什么的长期健康益处，或者我是否选择锻炼，会被，你知道，留下来看另一场演出或吃点此时此刻对我来说美味的东西所抵消。同样，当我们思考其他类型的“应该”时，那些同样抽象的权衡也会发挥作用。比如我应该关心全球范围内在世界其他地方受苦的人们。但当那是抽象的，而且，你知道，我们知道关于人们正在死亡的统计数据时，这可能不如我们听到关于特定个人受苦的具体故事，或者当我们了解那些生活受到特定政策或决策影响的人们时，更显著。艾米丽，我们让自己容易失去行为控制的另一种方式是，我们认为自己是独立的、自主的代理人。但你说大脑对其他人所想和所做的事情非常敏感，通过你所说的社会相关性系统。这是什么，艾米丽？是的，社会相关性系统是一组帮助我们理解其他人所想和所感的大脑区域。
policies or decisions that are being made. Another way, Emily, that we make ourselves vulnerable to losing control of our behavior is that we think of ourselves as independent, autonomous agents. But you say the brain is exquisitely sensitive to what other people think and do by what you call the social relevance system. What is this, Emily? Yeah, the social relevance system is a set of brain regions that help us understand what other people think and feel.
所以你可能也会听到科学家提到心智理论系统或心理化系统，它帮助我们思考其他人的想法和感受。这个社会相关性系统可以帮助我们与其他人联系和协调。它也塑造了我们做出的决定。它让我们与其他人保持一致。它可以帮助我们跟上潮流，但它也可以做有害的事情，比如可能误导我们分享虚假的社交媒体帖子。所以你自己最近有一次经历，让你感受到了其他人的观点有多么强大的影响力。
And so you might also hear scientists refer to a theory of mind system or a mentalizing system that helps us think about other people's thoughts and feelings. And this social relevance system can help us connect and coordinate with other people. And it also shapes the decisions that we make. Like it keeps us aligned with other people. It can help keep us on trends, but it can also do harmful things like maybe diluting us into reshue. sharing a false social media post. So you yourself had an experience recently that gave you a sense of how powerfully influential the views of other people can be.
我听说它涉及演员本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇。是的。所以在我要告诉你的故事之前，我真的从来没有想过太多关于本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的事情。我的意思是，我想如果我看到他，我想到任何事情，那就是，那是一个家伙，他是一个长相相当普通的家伙。然后我的朋友丽贝卡给了我一本书，叫《这不是一本关于本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的书》，其中，一位澳大利亚作家塔比莎·卡尔·范花了数百页谈论本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇有多棒，她认为他
And I understand it involved the actor Benedict Cumberbatch. Yeah. So before the story I'm about to tell you, I had really never thought very much about Benedict Cumberbatch. I mean, I think if I saw him and I thought anything, it was like, there's a guy like he's a pretty average looking guy um and then my friend rebecca gave me a book called this is not a book about benedict cumberbatch in which um an australian author tabitha car van spends a few hundred pages talking about how amazing benedict cumberbatch is she thinks he's
非常迷人，她只是，你知道，完全迷上了本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇。所以在读了这本书之后，这实际上是一本关于快乐、关于我们重视什么以及关于我们如何度过时间的一本书，我喜欢这本书，它让我思考，我想知道所有关于本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的兴奋是怎么回事。我对我的伴侣布雷特说，也许我们应该看《神探夏洛克》。布雷特说，哦，我已经看完了所有的《神探夏洛克》。我喜欢《神探夏洛克》。我说，什么？你什么时候看的《神探夏洛克》？但他会再看一遍，因为他显然也真的很喜欢本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇。他告诉我，他认为夏洛克是一个非常性感的角色。所以显然我，你知道，不合群。所以我们看了几集《神探夏洛克》。脑子里有别人的声音，我注意到，是的，他很有魅力，
incredibly attractive she just you know is completely enamored of benedict cumberbatch And so after reading this book, which is really a book about joy and about what we value and about how we spend our time, I loved the book, it made me think, like, I wonder what all the, you know, excitement about Benedict Cumberbatch is. And I said to my partner, Brett, like, maybe we should watch Sherlock. And Brett was like, oh, I've already watched all of Sherlock. I love Sherlock. And I was like, what? Like, when did you watch Sherlock? And but he said he'd watch it again because he apparently. also really likes Benedict Cumberbatch. And he told me that he thought Sherlock was a really hot character. So apparently I was, you know, out of line. So we watch a couple episodes of Sherlock. And with other people's voices in my head, I'm noticing, like, yeah, he's pretty charming,
他很聪明。然后我开始在网上看他接受采访的视频。你知道，人们问这些问题，比如，被评为在世最性感男人是什么感觉？他很迷人，对吧？他说了一些类似的话，哦，这让我咯咯笑。或者，你知道，他对此非常令人愉快。我的朋友们，你知道，我们开始谈论这个，结果证明我的朋友们认为本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇真的很有吸引力。所有这些只是让我重新考虑了我对本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的整个立场。
like, he's pretty smart. And then I started watching videos of him being interviewed online. and, you know, people asking these questions about, like, how does it feel to be named the sexiest man alive? And he's, like, so charming, right? He says something like, oh, it makes me giggle. Or, like, you know, he's totally delightful about it. And my friends, you know, we started talking about this, my friends, it turns out, thought Benedict Cumberbatch was really attractive. And all of this just made me, like, reconsider my entire position on Benedict Cumberbatch.
你应该看那个视频，他把企鹅发音错了，然后BBC记者问他，他说企鹅和“penwins”，他就是一直发音错误。峡湾冠企鹅以这位前南新西兰人命名。他在拍摄这部纪录片时似乎无法弄对，所以之后他们问他，
You should watch the video of where he mispronounce penguins and then a BBC reporter asks him about it and he says penguins and penwins like he just keeps mispronouncing it. Fjordland crested penguins named after this former of South New Zealand. He can't seem to get it right in filming this documentary and so then afterwards they ask him about it
他完全承认了，是的，这很难，他对此非常可爱和自嘲。再试一次“企鹅”这个词。也许，也许。也许他们只是放弃了。所以你被吸进了本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的入口。是的，我的意思是，就像研究中的人们一样，
and he just totally fasses up like, yeah, it's having a hard time and he's like so like lovely and self-deprecating about the whole thing. Just try the word penguin again. Maybe, maybe. Maybe they just gave up. So you got sucked into the Benedict Cumberbatch portal. Yeah, I mean, like the people in the study,
并不是说我一定会说我认为他是地球上最有吸引力的人。但我从认为，好吧，这是一个普通的家伙。我真的不知道大惊小怪的是什么，转变为欣赏他至少在互联网上表现出来的迷人本质，对吧？
it's not like I would necessarily say that I think that he is the most attractive person on the face of the planet. But I went from thinking like, all right, here's an average guy. I don't really know what the fuss is all about to appreciating the charming nature of at least how he comes across on the internet, right?
我认为这种增加的欣赏几乎完全是由这种其他人欣赏他的社会力量所激发的。我们喜欢认为我们是自己船的船长，但日常生活的事实讲述了一个不同的故事。掌舵处有一位副船长，而这位副船长并不总是与我们的目标一致。
And I think that that increased appreciation was motivated almost exclusively by this kind of social force of other people appreciating him. We like to think that we're captains of our own ships, but the evidence of everyday life tells a different story. There is a co-captain at the helm, and this co-captain does not always share our goals.
当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何做出我们说我们想要的改变。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家和神经科学家艾米丽·福克是《我们重视什么：选择与改变的神经科学》的作者。她花了很多年研究为什么我们的大脑似乎有自己的想法，以及为什么我们的决议和计划经常被劫持和阻碍。如果你在听完今天的对话后对艾米丽有后续问题或想法，并且你愿意与《Hidden Brain》的听众分享这些想法，请在你的手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件给我们，地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“心理障碍”。那个电子邮件地址再次是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。艾米丽，你知道，得知价值系统在某种意义上为我们做出判断可能会令人沮丧。而这些判断往往与我们说我们想要的判断不同。你说通过了解价值系统的运作，我们可以学会与大脑中的网络合作，
When we come back, how to make the changes we say we want. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. Psychologist and neuroscientist Emily Falk is the author of what we value, the neuroscience of choice and change. She has spent many years studying why our brains seem to have minds of their own, and why our resolutions and plans often get hijacked and waylaid. If you have follow-up questions or thoughts for Emily after listening to today's
而不是与它抗争。你是什么意思？是的，我的意思是，当我们思考我们更大的蓝图目标和价值观，甚至我们可能拥有的小目标时，我们构建这些选择的方式可以使做出与我们最终想要的选择相一致的选择变得更容易，如果我们，比如说，以我们最好的状态运作的话。所以我非常喜欢的一个例子是斯坦福大学的研究人员做的一项研究，他们观察了人们在食堂里的决定，他们改变了食物的标签，要么关注事物的长期健康益处，要么关注短期口味。所以，例如，他们可能有被标记为健康选择的芜菁，或香醋釉芜菁，或
conversation, and you're willing to share those thoughts with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, mental barriers. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Emily, you know, it can be dispiriting to learn that the value system is in a sense making our judgments for us. And these judgments are often different from the ones we say that we want. You say that by understanding the operation of the value system, we can learn to work with the network in the brain.
营养丰富的青豆，或滋滋作响的四川青豆。菜本身完全一样。但当他们突出选项的美味时，人们选择的蔬菜比他们突出那种长期健康益处时要多得多。所以当我谈到我们可以与我们的价值系统合作时，我的意思是，就像建立在我们之前谈到的基础上，人们倾向于优先考虑我们选择的直接或心理上接近或生动的后果，我们可以专注于什么是令人满意的，什么是奖励的，什么是我们想做的事情中立即有用的。在某些方面，这与试图对抗我们的价值系统是一个非常不同的模型，对吧？
brain rather than struggling against it. What do you mean by this? Yeah, what I mean is that when we think about our bigger picture goals and values or even small goals that we might have, that the way that we frame those choices can make it easier to make choices that are congruent with what we would ultimately want if we were, let's say, operating as our best selves. So one example that I really like is a study that researchers at Stanford did where they looked at people's decisions in dining halls and they changed the labels of the foods to either focus on the long-term health benefits of things or the kind of short-term taste. So, for example, they might have vegetables that were labeled as healthy choice turnips or balsamic glazed turnips or
因为它不等于说，我的价值系统想要X。我要运用意志力来压制它。它基本上是在说我们如何真正地一起工作？没错。我们如何与自己合作，以便做出现在感觉良好、以后也感觉良好的选择？所以如果我们考虑一个锻炼的例子，你知道，也许我们尝试做一些我们认为会让我们尽可能健康的事情，我们选择了一些最终并不那么有趣或令人愉快的事情，我们需要运用大量的意志力来强迫自己去做。那可能不是可持续的。然而当我们，
nutritious green beans or sizzling seschuan green beans. And the dish itself is exactly the same. But when they foreground the tastiness of the option, people chose a lot more vegetables than when they foreground that sort of longer term health benefit. And so what I mean when I say that we can work with our value system is like building on what we talked about before where people tend to prioritize the immediate or psychologically close or vivid consequences of our choices, we can focus on what is gratifying, what is rewarding, what is immediately useful about the thing that we want to do. And in some ways, this is a very different model than trying to fight our value system, right?
做出真正有趣和快乐的选择时。比如也许我真的很喜欢跳舞。所以对我来说去跳舞感觉不像，你知道，专门的锻炼。它感觉像是我想要做的事情，你知道，为了我的心理健康，即使没有身体上的好处。或者和我的邻居去跑步是赶上她并听听她这一周过得如何的好机会。所以专注于这些事情可以使它立即变得有益，而不是仅仅专注于一些关于变得更健康的长期目标，而实际上，它也具有那些好处。我听说你很长一段时间以来都有一个更频繁地去看望你祖母的打算。
Because it's not the same thing as saying, my value system wants X. I'm going to exercise willpower to suppress. it. It's basically saying how do we actually work together? Exactly. How do we collaborate with ourselves in order to make the choices that feel good now and feel good later? So if we think about an exercise example, you know, maybe we try to do something that we think is going to make us as fit as possible and we choose something that isn't ultimately that fun or enjoyable and where we have to exercise a lot of willpower to make ourselves do it. And that's probably not sustainable. Whereas when we,
你告诉我你和她很亲近，但你一直未能坚持你的决议，因为你害怕在去她家的路上会遇到的交通。所以记住我们刚才谈到的，与价值系统合作而不是对抗它的想法。艾米丽，你做了什么？我当时正在听一个叫《如何拯救地球》的播客，肯德拉·皮尔·刘易斯做了一集关于骑自行车的非常令人愉快的节目。它提醒我，骑自行车不必是那种你拿生命冒险在车流中穿梭的汗流浃背、压力重重的活动。就像肯德拉在骑自行车那一集中采访的人们只是在玩得开心。就像他们在外面快乐地骑着自行车摇摇晃晃。
make choices that are really fun and joyful. Like maybe I really love to dance. So going dancing for me doesn't feel like, you know, a workout specifically. It feels like something I would want to do, you know, for my mental well-being, even absent the physical benefits. Or going for a run with my neighbor is a great chance to catch up with her and hear about how her week is going. So focusing on those kinds of things can make it immediately rewarding as opposed to just focusing on some longer-term, about getting healthier, when in reality, it also has those benefits as well. I understand that for a long time you had an intention to visit your grandmother more often.
这让我思考了可能性。我可以骑自行车去她家，而不是开车去。你做了什么？嗯，我从地下室拿出我的自行车，在一个美丽的秋日下午沿着我的街道骑行，我骑到了带我沿着河边路线的小径，那真的很美。所以很快我就在那条慢跑小径上，但我只是飞快地超过了慢跑者，阳光在斯库尔基尔河上反射，我感觉棒极了。
You told me that you are close to her, but you kept failing to keep your resolution because you dreaded the traffic you would encounter on the way to her house. So keeping in mind what we just talked about, the idea of working with the value system rather than against it. What did you do, Emily? I was listening to a podcast called How to Save a Planet where Kendra Pier Lewis made this very delightful episode about biking. And it reminded me that biking doesn't have to be this like sweaty, stressful thing where you're taking your life in your hands weaving in and out of traffic. Like the people that Kendra interviewed for the biking episode were just having fun. Like they were out there joyfully teetering around on their bikes.
就像，我从我住的西费城一直骑到她住的艺术博物馆附近，处于一种感觉这就是我现在想待的地方的状态。就像，我在这美丽的秋日下午出来，拥有那段户外时间，拥有那段属于我自己的时间感觉真的很好。我的意思是，在某些方面，我认为我们中的一些人回避这样做，因为它几乎感觉像是在作弊。因为在某些方面，你现在去看望你的祖母部分是因为你实际上喜欢骑自行车。你喜欢在户外。
And it made me think about the possibility. that I could bike to her house instead of driving there. What did you do? Well, I got my bike out of the basement, and I biked down my street on a beautiful fall afternoon, and I biked up to the path that takes me to the route along the river, which is really beautiful. So pretty soon I was on this jogging path, but I was just flying past the joggers, and the light was reflecting off of the Schuylkill River, and I just felt amazing.
你喜欢斯库尔基尔河的样子。我想也许我们中的一些人脑子里认为，事情要好，它们实际上必须是困难的。如果锻炼要有意义，它必须涉及痛苦。而你所说的是，不，它不需要。没错。我认为，你知道，在我们生活中我们可以找到快乐时刻、联系时刻、幸福时刻的更多地方，我认为我们应该在能抓住它们的地方抓住它们。艾米丽和其他研究人员发现，当我们能将决议与我们的身份方面，或者研究人员所称的大脑中的自我相关网络联系起来时，我们的决议更有可能坚持下去。我认为我们可以做的一件事是思考我们的目标是如何成为我们想做的事情，但我们可能不会立即将它们与我们的感觉联系起来。
Like, I went all the way from where I live in West Philadelphia over to where she lives near the Art Museum in this kind of state of feeling like this is exactly where I want to be right now. Like, I'm out on this beautiful fall afternoon, and having that time outside, having that me time felt really good. I mean, in some ways, I think some of us shy away from doing this because it almost feels like cheating. Because in some ways now, you're visiting your grandmother in part now because you actually like biking. You like being outside.
我从我住的西费城一路骑到她住的艺术博物馆附近，当时我感觉这就是我当下最想待的地方。就像是在这个美丽的秋日下午出门，享受那段户外时光，拥有属于自己的时间，感觉真的很好。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我认为我们有些人会回避这样做，因为这感觉就像是在作弊。因为在某种程度上，你现在去探望祖母，部分原因是因为你真的喜欢骑自行车。你喜欢待在户外。
You like the look of the Skulkeld River. And I think perhaps some of us have in our heads that for things to be good, they actually have to be hard. That if for exercise to be meaningful, it has to involve suffering. And what you're saying is, no, it doesn't. Exactly. I think that, you know, the more places in our life where we can find moments of joy, moments of connection, moments of happiness, like I think we should take them where we can get them. Emily and other researchers find that our resolutions are more likely to stick when we can link them with aspects of our identity, or what researchers call the self-relevance network in the brain. I think one thing that we can do is think about how the goals that we have are the things that we want to do, but that we might not necessarily immediately connect with our sense
你喜欢斯库尔基尔河的景色。我想也许我们有些人脑子里有种想法，认为事情要好，就必须得吃苦。如果锻炼要有意义，就必须包含痛苦。而你所说的是，不，并非如此。没错。我认为，你知道，在我们生活中，如果我们能在更多地方找到快乐的时刻、联系的时刻、幸福的时刻，我认为我们应该尽可能地去抓住它们。艾米丽和其他研究人员发现，当我们能将决心与我们的身份认同，或者研究人员所称的大脑中的自我相关网络联系起来时，这些决心就更有可能坚持下去。我认为我们可以做的一件事是思考我们的目标是如何成为我们想要做的事情，但我们可能并不一定会立即将其与我们的自我意识联系起来。
of who we are, could be connected to strengths we already have or things that we're already doing. So one thing that happened for me was, you know, I go for jogs mostly to de-stress, to blow off some steam, and I have two siblings who are much more serious runners. And one day my brother was pitching me on the idea that if I did some targeted workouts, that I could get faster. And initially I sort of wondered, like, why would I care about getting faster in the first place? Like, growing up, I was, you know, thought of myself probably more like as a nerd than as a jock. And it wasn't immediately part of my identity to think of myself as a runner in that way.
我们是谁，可能与我们已经拥有的优势或正在做的事情有关。对我来说，发生过这样一件事：我慢跑主要是为了减压、发泄情绪，而我有两个兄弟姐妹是更认真的跑步者。有一天，我哥哥向我推销一个想法，说如果我进行一些针对性的训练，我就能跑得更快。起初我有点纳闷，为什么我非得关心跑得快不快呢？从小到大，我可能更多地认为自己是个书呆子，而不是运动健将。以那种方式把自己看作一名跑步者，并不是我身份认同的一部分。
And my brother framed it a different way. He said, you know, academics often make really good runners because academics are good at planning. Academics are good at working hard on things that, you know, have some payoff in the long term. And so that shifted it from something where, you know, doing these harder workouts to get faster would just be to do it to something that I already had the skills. the disposition to do. He also added another social reward, which was that if I got faster, I could run with my brother and sister
但我哥哥换了一种说法。他说，学术界人士通常能成为很好的跑步者，因为他们擅长规划。学术界人士擅长在长期有回报的事情上努力工作。因此，这就不再仅仅是为了跑得更快而进行艰苦训练，而是变成了我本身就具备相关技能和倾向去做的事情。他还增加了一个社交奖励，那就是如果我跑得更快，我就能和我的兄弟姐妹一起跑步，
and hear the gossip, which, of course, is very motivating for me. Was your brother, you think, aware of what he was doing? Was he just sort of offering this as a helpful piece of guidance, or had he read some of your work and figured out that this was what was going to be effective? Well, I don't know if he had read my work specifically,
还能听到八卦，这对我来说当然非常有动力。你觉得你哥哥意识到他在做什么吗？他是只是提供了一些有益的指导，还是他读过你的一些作品，并发现这样做会很有效？嗯，我不知道他是否专门读过我的作品，
but I think it was a strategic way to frame things. Because in some ways, I think what he got you to do was instead of saying, Emily is not a runner, he got you to say, well, running is the kind of thing that Emily should be doing. And in some ways, that's a very clever and important shift. Exactly. And so, you know, I will admit I'm not like doing speed workouts all the time. But after learning a little bit about what I was capable of by doing that, with my brother and with my sister, now at the end of my run, sometimes I will work in a little
但我认为这是一种策略性的表达方式。因为在某种程度上，我认为他让你做的是，不再说“艾米丽不是跑步者”，而是让你说“嗯，跑步是艾米丽应该做的事情”。在某种程度上，这是一个非常聪明且重要的转变。没错。所以，你知道，我承认我并不是一直在做速度训练。但在通过和哥哥姐姐一起跑步了解到自己的能力后，现在在跑步结束时，有时我会多做一点，
bit more, you know, I'll push myself for the last couple blocks to see how fast I can run or do those little things that over the long run, they promise me are going to make me a faster runner. And when I do that in my runs, then it gets incorporated into my identity and there's this feed-forward cycle of the more that I think of it as something that I do, the more I do it. And of course, when we think about our self-identities, there are some things that feel very core to our. So you might have previously thought, you know, I'm an academic. I'm primarily interested in the world of ideas. You know, running is not for me. But your brother found a way in some ways of connecting one aspect of what it means to be an academic with a very central
你知道，最后几条街我会逼自己一把，看看我能跑多快，或者做那些他们承诺长期来看会让我跑得更快的琐事。当我跑步时这样做，它就融入了我的身份认同，并形成了一个前馈循环：我越认为这是我做的事情，我就做得越多。当然，当我们思考自我认同感时，有些东西感觉非常核心。你可能以前认为，我是个学者，我主要对思想世界感兴趣，跑步不适合我。但你哥哥找到了一种方法，将作为学者的一个方面与作为跑步者的一个核心方面联系起来。
aspect of what it means to be a runner. And that tells me that in many ways, as we're looking for things to do, there are probably ways to harness many of the goals we have with aspects of our identity that in some ways that we're not doing already. That if we're strategic about how we connect our resolutions to our identities, we can find things in our core identities that are better harnessed or connected to our resolutions. That's right. So let's say that you have somebody that you work with who is really nervous about making a big presentation. And they don't necessarily think of themselves as being a great presenter. But you've seen them at the office party and you know that they are an extrovert who is the life of the party. And so you might help
这告诉我，在很多方面，当我们寻找要做的事情时，很可能有一些方法可以将我们的许多目标与我们身份中尚未利用的方面联系起来。如果我们能策略性地将决心与身份联系起来，我们就能在核心身份中找到能更好地与决心结合的切入点。没错。假设你有一位同事，他对做大型演讲感到非常紧张。他们不一定认为自己是一位出色的演讲者。但你在公司聚会上见过他们，你知道他们是一个外向的人，是聚会的灵魂人物。所以你可能会帮助
them see the connection between that way that they are able to connect with other people in a crowd in one situation with that same kind of connection that they might have in other situations. And so as we think about, you know, what are the goals that we have and what are the things that are getting in the way? One of the things that might be getting in the way is if we think, well, I'm not a person who does X. And in reality, we can shift to think about like, well, what are the things that are true of me that could support being able to do that thing? We talked earlier about the power of our social worlds
他们看到在一种情况下与人群建立联系的方式，与他们在其他情况下可能建立的联系是相同的。因此，当我们思考我们的目标是什么，以及什么在阻碍我们时，其中一个阻碍因素可能是我们认为“我不是做某事的人”。而实际上，我们可以转而思考“关于我，有哪些事实可以支持我去做那件事？”我们之前谈到了社交世界在塑造价值体系和大脑方面的力量，艾米丽。你说利用社会影响力的一个方法是使用心理学家所说的“社会认同”。我们之前在节目中讨论过这个概念，但什么是社会认同？它是如何运作的，我们如何利用它？社会认同是指我们受到周围人行为或想法影响的观念。所以当我们看到别人在做某事时，这会让我们认为这是一个好主意。社会认同往往在人们意识之外影响着他们。
in shaping the value system and the brain, Emily. You say that one way to enlist the power of social influence is to make use of what psychologists call social proof. Now, we've discussed this idea previously on the show, but what is social proof? How does it work and how can we take advantage of it? Social proof is the idea that we are influenced by what the people around us are doing or thinking. And so when we see that other people are doing something, then that makes us think that it's a good idea. And social proof influences people often outside of their
甚至在意识之外。例如，在加利福尼亚州，研究人员研究了不同人、不同家庭的能源使用情况。他们发现，当询问人们认为什么在影响他们的能源使用行为时，人们说成本和其他因素在影响，但他们并不认为邻居的能源使用对他们的决定有特别大的影响。然而，当研究人员观察时，
conscious awareness even. So, for example, in California, researchers studied the energy use of different people, of different households. And what they found was that when they asked people what they thought was influencing their energy use behaviors, that people said that, you know, their costs and other factors were influencing it. But they didn't actually think that their neighbor's energy use was particularly impactful in their decisions. And yet, when the researchers look at it.
观察到底是什么在影响他们的决定时，结果发现其他人的能源使用行为对这些人的行为有很强的预测作用。因此，基于此，研究团队进行了一项实验，他们给一些人提供了侧重于社会认同的信息。例如，“圣马科斯 77% 的居民经常使用风扇代替空调来在夏天降温”。这是一条强调你的许多邻居都在这样做信息。而其他人收到的信息侧重于仅仅要求他们考虑如何节约能源，例如通过使用风扇代替空调。还有其他人收到的则是其他类型的诉求，比如
looked at what was actually influencing their decisions, it turned out that other people's energy use behavior was pretty predictive of what those folks were doing. And so based on that, what the research team did was they ran an experiment where they gave some people messages that were focused on social proof. Like, for example, 77% of San Marcos residents often use fans instead of air conditioning to keep cool in the summer. So that's a message that's highlighting that a lot of your neighbors are doing this thing. And other people got messages that were focused on, you know, just asking them to consider how they might conserve energy. Like, for example, by using fans instead of air conditioning. And other people got other kinds of appeals, so things
省钱。研究人员发现，那些被告知邻居节约能源努力的家庭，最终比其他组的人节省了更多的能源。我认为这项研究最迷人的一点是，那些受到信息影响的人仍然报告说，其他人在做什么
like saving money. And they found, the researchers found, that the households that were told about their neighbors' conservation efforts, that they ended up saving more energy than people in the other groups. And the thing that I think is really fascinating about this study is that those folks who are influenced by the messages still reported that what other people were doing
是他们做出能源决策时最不重要的原因。所以我了解到你在实验室里有一种非常有趣的利用社会影响力的方法，它涉及到一个你称之为“WADI”的东西，什么什么什么？是的，那个术语的功劳归于埃利奥特·伯克曼，他也是一位研究目标追求的神经科学家。
was the least important reason for them making the energy decisions that they were making. So I understand that you have a very interesting technique of deploying social influence with others in your lab, and it involves working on something that you call wattied what-watt-what-what? Yeah, well, that term, the credit goes to Elliot Berkman, who's also a neuroscientist
“WADI”是“Work on that thing you don't want to work on time”（在那个时间处理你不想做的事情）的首字母缩写。有很多事情我们不一定想做，你知道，我们不想做但知道必须做的事情。我们在实验室里所做的是，通过一起做这些我们知道自己不想做的事情，让它们变得更有回报。所以有人可能会在我们的消息平台上发布：“有人想参加‘处理那件事’的会议吗？”然后一群其他人就会聚在一起。
who studies goal pursuit. The idea of wadi-wat-wat-wat is an acronym for work on that thing you don't want to work on time. There are a lot of things that we don't necessarily want to do, you know, things that we don't feel like doing, but that we know we need to do. And what we do in our lab is we try to make those things that we know we don't really want to work on more rewarding by doing them together. So somebody might post on our messaging platform. You know, does anybody want to have a work on that thing session and then a bunch of other people will get together?
其理念是设定一段时间。你不必永远做那件你不想做的事情。但我们互相支持和鼓励，并对这件事负责。所以有其他人在场有助于重新平衡价值计算，因为和别人叙旧很有趣，而且承诺和别人一起做这件事也利用了社会奖励的理念，
And the idea is that there's a set amount of time. You don't have to do a thing that you don't want to do forever. But we give each other support and encouragement. and hold each other accountable for the thing. And so having somebody else there kind of helps rebalance the value calculation because it's fun to get to catch up with somebody else and committing to doing it together with somebody else taps into that idea of social rewards as well
并使我们更有可能完成它。所以你在处理目标的不同方法上有自己的经验。有一次，你试图学习弹吉他，你有过不同的老师，他们强调吉他的不同方面。告诉我你与这些不同老师的经历，以及什么被证明是最有效的。是的。
and makes it more likely that we'll get it done. So you've had your own experience with different approaches to working on a goal. At one point, you were trying to learn to play the guitar, and you've had different teachers who've emphasized different aspects of the guitar. Tell me about your experience with these different teachers and what's proven to be most effective. Yeah.
2019 年，我父亲去世了。我成长过程中，父亲总是弹吉他，让我们的房子充满音乐。他会过来和我的孩子们一起玩，我年轻时，我们会唱歌，他会弹摇滚乐或民谣之类的东西。他去世后，我非常强烈地感受到了那种缺失。
In 2019, my dad died, and my dad, when I was growing up, would always play the guitar and fill our house with music. He would come over and play with my kids, and when I was younger, we would sing, and he would play rock and roll music or folk music, other kinds of things. And after he died, I really felt that absence very strongly.
以至于我决定要学习弹吉他。我开始尝试弄清楚该怎么做。我在网上看视频，试图激励自己。我了解到我很幸运，宾夕法尼亚大学有一个项目，他们会为你联系一位音乐老师。所以我联系了一位很棒的音乐老师。他非常热情。他是一位古典吉他手。但他也非常专注于古典音乐。
And so much that I decided that I was going to learn how to play the guitar. And I started trying to figure out how to do that. I watched videos online, and I was trying to motivate myself. And I learned that I'm really lucky that at Penn there's a program where they will connect you with a music teacher. And so I got connected with a music teacher who was great. He was really enthusiastic. He was a classical guitarist. But he was also really focused on classical music.
我有一个出于非常个人原因学习弹吉他的目标。当我问他关于我父亲喜欢的音乐，或者我和父亲一起弹奏的音乐时，他表现得好像是“是的，你会弄明白的”，但这并不是我们一起练习的核心。所以我会在练习时贿赂自己。比如，“好吧，如果你练习 10 分钟，最后就可以吃一颗巧克力松露之类的。”而且，你知道，再次尝试让奖励尽可能接近。但这很难。
And I had this goal to learn how to play the guitar for really personal reasons. And when I asked him about, you know, the kinds of music that my dad liked or that my dad and I would play together, it was sort of something that he was like, yeah, you'll figure that out. but it wasn't central to the practice that we were doing together. And so I would kind of bribe myself through practice sessions. Like, all right, if you practice for 10 minutes, then you can eat a chocolate truffle at the end or something. And, you know, again, trying to like bring the reward as close as possible. But it was hard.
疫情爆发了，由于种种原因，我暂停了课程。但后来，随着疫情缓解，我的孩子们回到学校面对面上课，我又有了更多的时间，我决定再试一次。我得到了一位主要教孩子们的吉他老师的推荐。我认为这很关键，因为你知道，一位真正教孩子的吉他老师能说明他们愿意参与什么。我遇到了加布里埃尔，他现在是我的吉他老师，也是我儿子西奥的吉他老师。加布里埃尔采取了完全不同的方法。他非常关注我为什么要弹琴，他会把我父亲弹琴的小音频片段拿来，为我转录，
And the pandemic struck and I paused the lessons for lots of reasons. reasons. But then, you know, as the pandemic eased and my kids went back to school face to face, I had a little bit more bandwidth again and I decided I was going to try again. And I got a recommendation for a guitar teacher who mostly teaches kids. And I think that's key because, you know, a guitar teacher who really teaches kids tells you something about what they're willing to engage with. And I met Gabriel, who's who's my guitar teacher now and also my son Theo's guitar teacher. And Gabriel took a totally different approach. So he was very focused on why I wanted to play and he would take little like audio clips that I had of my dad playing and transcribe them
并让我列出我感兴趣的歌曲清单，然后他会根据我的水平将它们写出来。所以当我练习时，突然间它不再感觉像工作了。它不再感觉像“好吧，现在我在做练习曲，我在做那件以后会让我达到目标的困难事情”。我已经身处其中了，对吧？我已经是在做那个未来的目标了，只是在一个适合我的水平上。而且，你知道，这对我的孩子们也很有效，他们可以选择他们开始时想学的音乐。而且，你知道，他有时也会让他们做练习，但他会将其与他们的目标、他们想练习的特定歌曲的动力联系起来。然后它
for me and asked me for a list of songs that I was interested in, and then he would write them out at a level that was appropriate for where I was. And so when I was practicing, all of a sudden now it didn't feel like work. It didn't feel like, okay, now I'm doing my etudes and I'm doing the hard thing that's going to get me to this goal later. I was already there, right? I was already doing the thing that was the future goal, just at a level that was appropriate for. me. And, you know, that's worked really well for my kids, too, that they get to choose the music that they start with. And, you know, he has them do exercises sometimes as well, but he connects it to their goal, their motivation of the particular song that they want to work on. And then it
就不会让人觉得我们现在的重复练习和未来某个抽象的、你知道的、我们能够演奏音乐的时间之间存在隔阂。我的意思是，加布里埃尔做了我们在这次谈话中谈到的这么多事情，这让我非常震惊，艾米丽。他基本上问你，什么与你的生活相关？我们如何让乐趣现在就开始，而不是以后才开始？我们如何让它尽可能易于获取且与自我相关？所以你在指导自己的学习过程。我的意思是，在某种程度上，他是你的学生，就像你是他的学生一样。嗯，是的，我的意思是，我真的很欣赏他这样做的方式。
doesn't make it feel like there's a separation between the repetitions and the practice that we're doing right now and some future abstract, you know, time when we're going to be able to play music. I mean, I'm so struck that Gabriel did so many of the things that we've talked about in this conversation, Emily. He basically asked you, what's relevant to your life? How do we make the fun start now, as opposed to start later on? How do we make this as accessible and as self-relevant as possible? So you are directing your own course of learning. I mean, in some ways, he is a student of yours as much as you are a student of his. Well, yeah, I mean, I really appreciate the way that he has done that.
而且，你知道，也只是为我为什么在那里留出空间。比如，有时在开始时我会变得非常情绪化。这似乎并没有让他慌乱。他只是会等一等，或者也许坐在那里自己弹一会儿。我认为这种整体的理解，比如有时我们把事情分割开来，比如“好吧，我们在这里是因为我要试着让艾米丽学会弹吉他”，而不是“我们在这里是为了共同拥有这种体验”。所以，当我试图让我的孩子们练习时，我会尝试引导这种感觉。西奥弹吉他，
And, you know, also just holding space for why I was there. Like, sometimes at the beginning I would get really emotional. And that didn't seem to fluster him. He would just kind of wait or maybe sit there and play himself for a little bit. And I think that kind of holistic understanding of like sometimes we kind of segment off, like, okay, we're here because I'm going to try to get Emily to learn how to play the guitar, rather than, like, we're here to have this experience together. And so, like, I try to channel some of that when I'm trying to get my kids to practice. Theo plays the guitar and
艾玛和加布里埃尔学钢琴。而且，你知道，如果我坐在那里和西奥一起练习，而他开始弹奏一些技术上不是他本周作业的其他歌曲时，当我处于最佳状态时，我可以退后一步，思考一下，其实这一切的目标是为了让我们能够建立联系并一起做这件有趣的事情。所以，与其说“嘿，你应该花 10 分钟专注于巴赫”，不如说我可以提醒自己，其实这就是我们试图做的事情。我们现在就在做，而不是像，你知道，他可能永远不会成为音乐会演奏家。所以，这就是我们在这里的原因。
Emma plays the piano with Gabriel. And, you know, if I'm sitting there practicing with Theo and he starts, you know, playing some other song that's not technically his homework for the week, when I'm being my best self, I can take a step back and think about like, well, actually the goal of this whole thing is for us to be able to connect and do this fun thing together. And so rather than being like, hey, you're supposed to spend 10 minutes focusing on Bach, like, you know, I can remind myself that like actually this is the thing that we're trying to do. We're doing it right now rather than like, you know, he's probably never going to be a concert musician. And so, so this is why we're here.
我的意思是，在某种程度上，这触及了一个非常重要的观点，艾米丽，那就是我认为我们经常对自己有这种非常割裂的看法。所以我们有一种人的感觉，说“我想成为，你知道，随便选个决心，我想更健康，我想少吃甜点，我想练习钢琴，我想给祖母打电话”，我们有一种非常割裂的看法，说“我怎样才能让其余的自己与我必须做这件特定事情的愿景保持一致？”这是一种非常自上而下的、几乎是等级森严的关于我们如何想象自己行为和存在的愿景。我认为你在这里用加布里埃尔所描述的实际上是
I mean, in some ways, this speaks to a really important idea, Emily, which is that I think we often have this very compartmentalized view of our own cells. So we have the sense of the person who says, I want to be, you know, whatever, pick the resolution, I want to be healthier, I want to be, you know, eat less dessert, I want to practice the piano I want to call my grandmother, and we have this very compartmentalized view of saying, how do I make the rest of me fall in line with this vision that I have to do this particular thing? And it's a very top-down, almost hierarchical vision of how we imagine ourselves behaving and being. And I think what you're describing here with Gabriel is actually something
更整合的东西，在某种程度上你是一个完整的艾米丽。你是你所爱和怀念的人的女儿，你是音乐家，你是学生，你是学者，这都是一个人。不是五个不同的人在互相打仗。是的，我的意思是，即使只是想到这一点，也让我感到情绪激动。但有一件事浮现在脑海中，那就是我父亲过去常弹的一段热身曲。
that's much more integrated, where in some ways you are one Emily. You are the daughter of someone who you loved and who you miss, and you're the musician and you're the student, and you're the academic, and it's all one person. It's not five different people at war with each other. Yeah, I mean, it makes me feel emotionally even just thinking about it. But one thing that comes to mind is there's this, like, warm up that my dad used to play.
我记得当我把那个 MP3 给加布里埃尔时，他回来后就在弹奏它。我在客厅里。结果发现它其实非常简单。这是我有能力做到的事情。那种与一个不在身边的人建立联系的感觉，但我们有过和他们一起做一些非常特别的事情的经历，感觉真是太好了。
And, I remember when I gave that MP3 to Gabriel and he came back and he was playing it. I was in the living room. And it turned out that it was actually like really simple. And it was something that I did have access to be able to do. And that kind of like feeling connected to somebody who's not physically there, but where we've had. the experience of doing something really special with them, like, just felt so good.
而且，你知道，现在，嗯，和我的孩子们一起玩，当他们演奏音乐时，有时我们会选择我父亲写的歌，他们学习如何弹奏那些歌，或者我过去常和我父亲一起唱的歌。当我坐在那里，怀里抱着一个孩子，他膝盖上放着一把大吉他，我能在那儿唱歌，感觉就像一个非常圆满的
And, you know, now, um, playing with my kids, like when they play music, sometimes we choose songs that my dad wrote and they learn how to play those songs or, um, songs that I used to sing with my dad. And when I'm sitting there, like, with a kid snuggled in my lap and a big guitar on his lap and I get to sing there it feels like a really full circle
感觉，就像我没想到你会让我哭，感觉感觉太棒了。下周我们将为你带来我们与艾米丽谈话的第二部分。我们来看看改变的一个特定障碍。
kind of feeling like it feels like I did not expect for you to make me cry it feels it feels amazing Next week we bring you part two of our conversation with Emily. We look at one particular obstacle to change.
防御心理。你有没有注意到，当你向朋友、同事或伴侣提出改进建议时？他们经常会产生一种坚持己见的冲动，而不是听取他们如何改变或做得更好。他们试图维持现状。就像打仗的将军一样，他们试图保护自己作为人的每一寸土地，而不是拥抱他们可能成为的人。我们将与艾米丽讨论我们如何打破防御心理的障碍，
Defensiveness. Have you ever noticed when you offer a friend or a colleague or a partner a suggestion for improvement? They often experience an urge to do. dig in their heels rather than listening to how they might change or do something better. They try to preserve the status quo. Like generals fighting a war, they try to protect every square inch of the person they are instead of embracing the person they might become. We'll talk with Emily about how we can break through the barrier of defensiveness
并帮助我们生活中的人们做出有价值的改变。如果你有后续问题或想法想与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至 Ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“Mental Barriers”。再次重复该电子邮件地址：Ideas@hiddenbrain.org。艾米丽·福克是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《我们重视什么：选择与改变的神经科学》一书的作者。艾米丽，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢你的邀请。
and help the people in our lives make valuable changes. If you have follow-up questions or thoughts for Emily that you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, Mental Barriers. That email address again is Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Emily Fock is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Pennsylvania. She's the author of What We Value, the Neuroscience of Choice and Change. Emily, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是一群超级粉丝，他们最近在波士顿地区我们的“隐藏的大脑”现场演出后与我共进晚餐。劳拉·萨比亚、马修·弗莱明和迪娜·本·大卫，有机会与你们建立联系真是太好了。感谢你们对我们在“隐藏的大脑”工作的兴趣和支持。我们衷心感谢。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Wood. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Unsung Heroes this week are a group of super fans who join me recently for a meal after our Hidden Brain live show in the Boston area. Laura Sabia, Matthew Fleming, and Dina Ben David, it was wonderful to have the opportunity to connect with you. Thanks for your interest and support of our work at Hidden Brain. We're truly grateful.
如果你想支持我们的工作并获得你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅“隐藏的大脑 Plus”。在九月份加入 Apple Podcasts 的听众将获得 30 天的免费试用期。要订阅，请在 Apple Podcasts 上找到“隐藏的大脑”并尝试“免费试用”按钮。或者访问 Apple.com/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
If you'd like to support our work and have access to conversations you won't hear anywhere else, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. Listeners who join in the month of September on Apple Podcasts will have access to an extended 30-day free trial. To subscribe, find Hidden Brain on Apple Podcasts and try the try-free button. Or go to Apple.com slash Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想支持我们的工作并获得在其他任何地方都听不到的对话内容，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅服务 Hidden Brain Plus。在九月份通过 Apple Podcasts 加入的听众将获得 30 天的免费试用期。要订阅，请在 Apple Podcasts 上搜索 Hidden Brain 并点击免费试用按钮。或者访问 Apple.com/Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。再见。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。